do you guys think body count matters
yeah yes yes
100 is this for both genders yeah uh for
women let's say for women and then for
do women than men so okay oh not for men
no no matters for yeah God women yes
men not so much okay
no neither okay
I don't think it I think it only matters
how it's put out there
because somebody a woman can have a high
body cat nobody knows about it she
carries us or even men will know about
it and she carries herself different
member tree are different
but you can have somebody with a high
body care not even as high as that
woman's body care and it's all out there
for everyone to see it's all over the
internet then it matters because you
must know women that got high high body
Cuts you still respect them because the
way they carry themselves and normally
it's the older woman not the younger
woman because there's lots of older
women out there with high body counts
and people still respect them they're
the aunties they're the grandmas
but then you get the young women now and
they got high body count
and it's like a badge of honor
wouldn't you say it makes you less
valuable to men though the more men you
sleep with
yeah yeah the women don't know that
because they're always trying to get
that better man what women don't know
that women definitely know that well no
it's it's like a Coke if they did why
would it be sleeping or something
because
why would they bother us yeah I'll just
um just a quick start only 30 of
it um
when a woman gets married and she's a
virgin she has an 80 chance of a happy
marriage if she slept with more than
five people it drops to 30 percent wow
that means I'm at two percent
I got about two percent or something
like that
yeah and it does it's not like the
end-all it's not saying like every
single girl that slept around like
that's her fate but it's I think to say
that like sleeping around has good
is good for women is kind of a lie that
feminism teaches I think it's bad for
women I think it's bad for both but more
so for women because
with men there's a pride attached to it
with women there's a stigma attached to
it so I think nowadays the women are
trying to turn that stigma into pride
and it's not working yeah they're trying
that's where the modern women get lost
because that stigma of having a high
body count is no longer there they're
wearing it with pride I think it also
like from a male point of view it also
depends on the people she slept with to
a point as well because if for example
say you live in one of those areas and a
lot of people know each other
one okay one of men's biggest I don't
want to say nightmares but hang ups is
bumping into another guy like oh I know
you'll go like I know her exactly sorry
I think yeah you go actually the point
so bodycon uh for men so when you're
approaching a girl
because it actually touching your
confidence so since you know that your
women actually slept with 10 20 other
men you like losing confidence
and you're like worry your first worry
is like you know
get to know
so it's about you not about us well but
if you give something away for free it's
not valuable so if you if you feel free
if you're giving if you're giving it to
a lot of people it's not valuable so why
that doesn't like go buff away right
because because men and women are
different women are born with value
where men have men have to create their
values so for you to want to sleep with
a guy he's got to be tall he's got to be
good looking he's got to have a job like
he has to do things one out of three men
under 30 are virgins or haven't had sex
in the past year and women are sleeping
with five to twenty percent of guys so
the reason like women hate Madness
because we're all sleeping with the same
ones I'm not agreeing about this
honestly
um because the fact you as he said the
fact you slept with multiple men or
whatever how many they are doesn't
really it depends like was you actually
in a relationship with him oh it was
just occasional thing you know and I
also accept occasional stuff like
because was you know like if you match
someone and you you know you just want
to enjoy your day there's nothing wrong
with that and that's honestly no one
hello her men to tell me are less
vulnerable than someone else that had
sex just once well it's not it's like
it's not who you was my body gonna be
the same body and myself gonna be the
same person after 10 20 men it wouldn't
change it's not it's not anything about
who you are as a person but it's what
men value so you can't so so you can't
go up to guys and say don't value this
because it's what they want so that's
like me selling a car and going up to
the people that want to buy a car and
say like this car and they say no I
don't want to buy that car because it's
got too many miles and you're saying
well you should light cars with high
miles
so women can't get no title like that
because when she's saying that nobody's
gonna know you have about 30 Men You're
gonna be as loses held men no and like
the thing is you know and at the end of
the day every woman sleeps with loads of
men she's a she's a [__] if a man man
seeks of loads of women is a stud yeah
so that gets the show from the beginning
and that's I'm sorry but
use
we didn't make that rule as well no but
but that's the way it is
and at the end of the day right men
can I have loads of sex and it's always
going to be like women bro said
yeah so that's anywhere I can put it
you're gonna you're gonna know you can't
say oh it's my body because you're going
to be no my alignment so can help you
yeah because you get Trauma from
everyone like you can't you can't say
like a very okay that girl that came in
earlier you could tell she hadn't slept
with a lot of people because she was
just so nice and like like you can like
feel it on a girl right because they're
not they're not like traumatized because
if you sleep with 20 30 40 guys the odds
that one is gonna hurt you it's like
higher and higher and higher like how do
you go through that many guys and none
hurt you come on none you can't you kind
of unscathed come on that's not about
sexy it's not I mean a man doesn't
attitude just because you're having sex
with him he RT for a lot of other
reasons and doesn't matter the sex like
it's not about sex it actually adds you
when it does something wrong I don't
think he does something wrong in bed it
can do something wrong you know in any
other occasion actually probably they
gonna be good in bed and I'm probably
really doing but that's but that's like
a masculine trait is not being able to
bond with men through sex because women
tend to bond with men through sex unless
they've slept with a lot of people then
they don't while we don't just think
about that a woman can enjoy sex as a
man like like you can't enjoy catching
feelings no matter what
that's what you like to think that's
what you like to feel no you know I just
know quick quick just around guys in the
room I'm just asking have you ever slept
with a girl that said it was casual and
then she caught feelings yes yes
um yes
yes yes have you ever slept with a girl
that casually and then she caught
feelings yeah dude I don't know your
name but yes yes yeah give me yes or no
yeah yeah okay
so four random guys are in this room all
saying the same what about the opposite
why do you do the ask me what do you
mean if I stop any kind of you know
relationship with them because we
weren't talking about you we were
talking about the men yeah I mean as a
woman no me as a Alessandra like if that
can happen for a man he stopped to see
someone because he was catching feeling
that can happen also with a man the only
thing is um that men usually they just
don't say when they catch him feeling
because they feel like you know we it's
this
so it's not allowed to say yeah I'm
falling in love just having sex in with
it with you so you wouldn't say that he
wouldn't say that no but like Paul said
we don't really there's always going to
be exceptions to the rule but the
reality is it doesn't work both ways
listen if a man feelings from a woman is
with that woman forever yes he's gonna
stick with her
because if a woman if a woman catches
feeling she's gonna chase that man even
though it's a one-night stand but for
man gets feelings then that's his woman
that is his woman simple is that because
men hold men hold access or women are in
control of sex men are in control
relationships correct so again like it's
not it's not fun but it's just like how
the world is like there are double
standards for men and for women we're
different we don't operate the same way
and like guys are repulsed by girls that
have slept around women sleep with who
they want men sleep with who let them
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible